hey everyone welcome back to the channel
if you're new here my name is lucy and
i'm an associate solutions architect at
amazon web services today i'll be taking
you through what a day my life looks
like working from home
my alarm wakes me up at 8 20 and after
hitting the snooze button i slowly get
out of bed to wash my face brush my
teeth and get dressed
these days i find myself having the same
breakfast every day overnight oats with
blueberries i sit down to enjoy my food
and start checking my emails and slack
messages
it's 8 15 now which means i have my
first meeting of the day a 10 minute
catch up with an intern in my team
i'm her onboarding buddy so we catch up
every morning to chat about what she's
working on and what she needs help with
after the call i take a very long 5
second walk to my home office area and
plug my laptop into the monitor
i have a few more meetings today and one
of them is a customer meeting where they
would like some help with understanding
the features of amazon quicksite a
business intelligence service offered by
aws
i spent the next 45 minutes doing some
preparation for the customer meeting by
reading some blogs and documentation
about amazon quicksite alright so the
customer had a few questions around the
quicksite features and
some of the features that they mentioned
i thought it would be best for me to do
a bit of a demo to show them how it
actually works so what i've done is i've
built out an example dashboard and
during my call with the customer i'll be
able to walk through some of the
features by sharing my screen time went
by really fast and now it's time to head
to my next meeting
i have a one-on-one with the new
solutions architect who joined my team
this week we introduced ourselves talked
for around half an hour and i shared
some tips on how to make the most out of
the first few weeks of the roll i have
around half an hour before my next
meeting so i reply to some emails and
slack messages from earlier today at
11am i have a meeting with my manager
and we talk about what i've been working
on
this is the regular catch-up we have
over two weeks and i find it to be a
really good chance to ask questions and
make sure i'm on the right track it's 11
30 now and i head to the kitchen to have
some lunch what i love about working
from home is being able to make my own
healthy meals instead of having to spend
lots of money buying my lunch
today i'm making a salad bowl filled
with lettuce cucumbers tomatoes onions
chickpeas lemon and a spoonful of greek
yogurt seasoned it with some salt and
pepper and headed to the kitchen to eat
my lunch while watching some youtube
after taking a one hour lunch break i
head back to my desk for some final
preparation before my customer meeting
at 1pm i do some research on the company
their previous interactions with aws and
come up with some questions to ask them
during the call to better understand
their interest in using quicksite it's
time to meet with the customer and we
start off with some introductions since
this is our first conversation because
i'm still quite new to engaging with
customers i have asked another solutions
architect to join the court and provide
me with some feedback afterwards
okay so i've just had the meeting with
the customer and did a bit of a debrief
as well with the solutions architect i
think they really liked the demo and
were able to help them answer most of
their um questions and concerns so what
i'm gonna do now is i'm gonna be sending
up a follow-up email um with some links
and resources so that they can get
started with using amazon quicksite
okay so it's three o'clock now and
there's a workshop running for the
solutions architects summer interns a
couple of grads and i decided to
organize a series of q and a panels
technical workshops and lunch and learn
sessions for the interns over the summer
and we've been taking turns hosting the
different sessions today's workshop is
about one and a half hours and i decided
to tune in with some popcorn
all right so at five o'clock i finish
off my work for the day and head outside
for a walk i try to leave the house at
least every second day to make sure the
days don't blend in together as we
continue to work from home
at six o'clock i head home and start
cooking i moved out of my parents house
a couple of months ago and i've been
trying to make my own lunch and dinner
every day and not order ube eats some
days i just cave in and order fried
chicken but today my fridge is looking
pretty full so i'm definitely going to
be making my own dinner today on the
menu we have salmon with pasta and
broccoli i air fry the salmon and
broccoli adding some soy sauce and cook
my pasta on the side i eat my dinner
before it gets cold and turn on netflix
to watch another episode of manifest
it's about a family that gets split up
and end up boarding different airplanes
but one of the planes suddenly vanishes
and reappears on the ground five years
later it's pretty interesting i
recommend checking it out after washing
the dishes and cleaning the kitchen nine
o'clock is just me lying in bed watching
more netflix before getting ready for
bed okay so that was a day in my life as
an associate solutions architect at aws
i'm just trying to edit the video right
now so i can get it published but i
wanted to say please give this video a
like if you enjoyed it and if you have
any questions about the aws solutions
architect role
or any video suggestions as well leave
it down in the comments below it really
helps me out alright bye for now